la journaliste dounia h m bonjour
bonjour dounia h&m merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france comment le maroc fait
qu'il face à la pandémie
alors vous le disiez à l'instant depuis
deux semaines des millions de marocains
sont appelés à faire preuve de
discipline de responsabilité et de
solidarité
concrètement comment ça se traduit bien
casablanca comme partout au maroc les
écoles les restaurants les cafés les
commerces les mosquées aussi sont fermés
autant dire que les artères autrefois
bondé ne le sont plus actuellement
finies aussi les embouteillages
quotidiens de la capitale économique
globalement le confinement on peut dire
est respecté mais il est vrai que dans
certains quartiers certaines franges de
la population qui vivent dans des
conditions précaires et la promiscuité
ont plus de mal à respecter ces mesures
de distanciation sociale alors c'est
vrai que on indique 735 cas confirmés ça
paraît peu vu la proximité avec
l'espagne
oui tout à fait alors c'est vrai que
depuis deux semaines en tout les
citoyens sont appelés à rester chez eux
autant que possible certains peuvent
toutefois sortir pour aller travailler
quand le télétravail n'est pas possible
pour faire des courses ou recevoir des
soins mais pour ça chaque citoyen doit
être muni en fait d'un document officiel
signé par des agents d'autorité et pour
que la mesure soit respectée des
barrages des forces de l'ordre sont
positionnés à des points de passage
stratégique sur la voie publique pour
effectuer des contrôles et toute
personne qui ne respecte pas ces mesures
obligatoires risque justement des
sanctions prévues par le code pénal
donc à l'image de ce qui se fait en
france ici aussi les mesures d'isolement
sanitaires sont le seul moyen à ce jour
de limiter la propagation du coït 19
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est en
grande partie grâce à la fermeture de la
frontière avec l'espagne il ya trois
semaines qu'il y a peu de cas alors
l'espagne mais aussi la france l'italie
il ya beaucoup de marocains résidant à
l'étranger d'ailleurs les premiers cas
confirmés positifs au maroc venait
pour la majeure partie de ces trois pays
et depuis le 20 mars donc date à
laquelle l'état d'urgence sanitaire a
été décrété ici au maroc la population
vit à l'heure du confinement voulzy et
jusqu'au 20 avril
a priori difficile à l'heure actuelle de
dire si oui ou non le confinement sera
levé à cette date là précisément puisque
qui dit épidémie dit aussi ennemi
invisible imprévisible d'où l'importance
du confinement actuelle et depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire mondiale
le maroc assure plutôt une bonne gestion
les derniers chiffres avancés par le
ministère de la santé en témoigne 735
cas de contamination et le nombre de
guérisons dépasse celui des décès 49
contre 47 donc une bonne gestion de
crise c'est important de le souligner
aussi est d'autant plus nécessaire et
essentielle au maroc qu'à l'ordinaire
les conditions de travail dans l'hôpital
public sont difficiles à peine plus de
1600 lit en réanimation pour 35 millions
d'habitants tout de même et le pays a
donc organisé plusieurs hôpitaux au
niveau de ses douze régions pour
accueillir diagnostiquer traiter des
malades du colis de 19
il a aussi mis en renfort possible
jusqu'à 9000 lit des cliniques privées
ainsi que la capacité des forces armées
royales et les chu sont désormais
autorisés à effectuer des tests et après
le confinement et le royaume ambitionne
de tester massivement est ce que le
maroc en a les moyens alors que on pose
la question évidemment à la france aux
autorités françaises qui en manquent
oui alors j'imagine que la situation est
similaire pour beaucoup de pays
actuellement étant donné la crise de
sanitaires mondiales en tous cas depuis
l'arrivée du coc vide 19 au maroc
plus de 3400 test de dépistage par
technologie appelée pcr ont été
effectués la méthode est dit sûr mais
elle prend du temps elle est chronophage
et vu la vitesse de propagation de la
maladie
c'est une course contre la montre chaque
minute compte
et d'ici quelques jours d'ailleurs cent
mille tests de diagnostic rapides
devraient être disponibles donc on peut
dire qu'avec anticipation le maroc
prépare les futures étapes en cas de
poursuite de la propagation du virus
en tout cas les faits
confinement entrée en vigueur il y a
quinze jours maintenant devraient être
visibles éventuellement à partir de
cette fin de semaine en principe
dernière question non vous avez aussi
votre dr salomon comme en france qui
intervient tous les soirs pour faire de
la pédagogie il s'appelle mohamed al
youbi c'est le monsieur coronavirus chez
vous il est pris très au sérieux par les
marocains oui il est pris très au
sérieux
dans la mesure où comme vous disiez il
fait une conférence de presse
quotidienne
il rapporte les propos des autorités
et là encore je pense que c'est le cas
dans beaucoup de pays il ya beaucoup de
fausses informations c'est fake news qui
circulent autour de cette pandémie de
cette épidémie
donc là encore son image on va dire il
est là pour rapporter les propos les
dernières informations des autorités
donc c'est en ça où il est pris au
sérieux actuellement merci beaucoup
dounia h&m d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france